every day I wake up knowing that the
more people I try to save more enemies I
will make and it's just a matter of time
before I face those more power
I can overcome
I'm so sorry I'm late
I had a traffic thing did your traffic
jam have anything to do with being I
don't know shot at by a machine guns
yeah the house implies that was implying
that he's a park area husband you're
gonna want to see this Osborne and you
under surveillance
why isn't that the question of the day
something you're not telling me
I want to talk to this secrets have a
cost
my name is Richard Parker I have
discovered what Oscorp was going to use
my research for I have a responsibility
to protect the world from what I know
what about Peter not everyone has a
happy end
this is bigger than you Peter
I made a choice this is my Paul
everyone has said
to live
hey youtubers it's Charlie so I just
wanted to do a quick trailer review of
the amazing spider-man 2 trailer that
just posted it's a bit of a teaser it's
not super long and it's a little
confusing but there are a lot of Easter
eggs too that we need to cover so first
things first the really obvious clear
big bad will be Jamie Foxx as electro
the other big villain will be Paul
Giamatti the Rhino but the Green Goblin
Norman and Harry Osborn will be in this
- Harry Osborn will be the one wearing
the suit so a lot of people are coming
down hard on the movie especially after
this trailer because it's starting to
look a lot like spider-man 3 but I think
we just have to wait and see what the
next trailer looks like I'm really
interested to see what Dane DeHaan Harry
Osborn looks like that should be a lot
of fun but it sounds like he's actually
going to be teaming up with Peter Parker
in this because in the trailer he talks
about challenges that he's not strong
enough to face so obviously he's going
to need a little bit of help from a
billionaire you know we just did a video
about arrow in the flash so obviously
arrow is going to be getting some puffs
from some other superheroes eventually -
so this is like the age of superhero
team-up we're all moving towards Justice
League obviously this is moving towards
sinister six so let's talk about those
sinister six Easter eggs those doctor
octopus's tentacles part of the sinister
six floaters wings part of the sinister
six
so right there including the people on
screen you basically almost have the
entire sinister six a lot of people are
reporting those Easter eggs are actually
inside the post-credits scene that would
be a really big deal to put your
post-credits scene in your trailer I
think that Sony is just trying to hedge
their bets in case people don't like
this movie they're just trying to keep
people as excited as possible I do agree
the trailer is a little incoherent but
it is exciting at the thought of a
sinister six movie so Sony is obviously
trying to pull a Marvel and just spinoff
while these are the franchises
I really hope that it works but let me
know what you think so if you didn't see
it already I just did a big flash Q&A
there's a big flash spin-off show that's
coming if you haven't seen about it yet
and arrow just introduced Barry Allen
you can click here to get that flash Q&A
and click here to get that arrow video
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow high fives
you